it sailed through space at an
unimaginable speed a grand mechanical
construction unlike anything we'd ever
seen on our planet a terrifying weapon
to end all weapons oppenheimer said of
the atomic bomb now i am become death
the destroyer of worlds but
comparatively this device made the atom
bomb look like little more than a cherry
bomb this deadly machine's orders were
simple take a direct course to earth
activate and wipe out all life leave the
planet barren with not even the smallest
squirming microbes remaining and this
device this destroyer was more than
capable of accomplishing this task it'd
been smooth sailing for millions of
miles all diagnostics were looking
positive within a mere decade or so the
human race would be purged from the
cosmos then faster than the
pre-programmed destroyer could react a
huge yellowish green shape appeared in
front of it the destroyer's mysterious
creators in their not quite infinite
intelligence had planned for all of the
major celestial bodies in earth's solar
system including jupiter but for reasons
unknown they hadn't calculated the
presence of io jupiter's third largest
galilean moon the destroyer struck it at
incredible speed causing a mighty
explosion and completely altering its
perfect trajectory alarms were sounding
as the destroyer hurled down onto the
lower atmosphere of jupiter this
alteration was unprecedented mayday
mayday in some distant galaxy screens
were flashing red and the creators
suddenly registered that this mission
may not be so simple after all they
would need to make adjustments the
impact into jupiter triggered the
destroyer's attack protocol drawing from
its limitless energy source it activated
its hyper-advanced anti-matter weaponry
causing spatial disruptions and
atmospheric shifts that created a huge
red vortex on the surface of the gas
giant one that would later become known
to earth-based astronomers as the great
red spot it's 16 350 kilometers wide
which is 1.3 times the size of planet
earth and it exists as a kind of hell
that almost no being could endure a
constant swirling nightmare with 432
kilometer per hour wind speeds in other
words the exact kind of nightmare it
would have turned earth into if ever it
had reached its actual intended
destination but no matter this was just
a minor setback all things considered
such contingencies had been planned for
from the start the creators back in the
triangulum galaxy roughly 3 million
light years away from the milky way
simply began transmitting new orders to
the crashed malfunctioning destroyer
unit is damaged repair and that's
exactly what it began to do it's unknown
how they were able to communicate let
alone travel over such a vast distance
but systems that would be impossible to
even explain to humans suddenly began to
kick in it released a legion of hearty
self-made octopod repair drones that
began to search for the machine's
missing parts presumably hidden within
the gases of jupiter or pulled in by the
gravity of its nearby moons other drones
would remain at the destroyer's side
conducting repairs and guiding its vital
systems presumably to this machine and
its creators humans are like mayflies
insignificant creatures with such tiny
lifespans here today gone tomorrow the
machine would conduct its repairs and be
upon us within a mere few centuries
barely even diverting from the schedule
the one thing the creators didn't
anticipate was the formation of a little
organization called the scp foundation
perhaps the only hope humanity has in
repelling this doomsday weapon the
question we need to answer today is will
they be enough terrifyingly this device
has been intent on our destruction since
long before the scp foundation was even
a glint in humanity's eye it entered our
solar system and crashed on jupiter all
the way back in 1665.
we know this thanks to the writings of
italian astronomer giovanni cassini who
recorded detailed notes in his journal
on what we would later dub as cp 2399
on october 8
1665 he wrote i have observed the
something extraordinary in the heavens
last night as i gazed through my looking
glass i saw what appeared to be a star
of great luminescence streak through the
far reaches of our solar system i have
never recorded an object moving so fast
it had surpassed the outer planets in
fewer than the two hours as i watched by
my own two eyes i saw it slow as it
closed on jupiter make a sharp turn and
disappear into the planet itself i saw
many bursts of light afterwards but
although i could continue to peer at it
until the sun broke i saw no additional
disturbances in the night sky i must
continue to document these changes and
will alert my colleagues when the day is
upon me on october 15th i took peter to
my observation point last night but the
weaker from the last night i saw the
fire reigned upon jupiter and the
heavens he brought along his own looking
glass and together we aimed our view
upon the giant to our surprise a
magnificent change had occurred where
once the distant world only showed bands
of color there was now a great red spot
where the star came to rest on the
surface of jupiter peter was incredulous
of course that such an amazing discovery
could have taken place before our very
eyes i will continue to take note of
this on october 18th tonight as i peered
through my looking glass i swear on my
life that i observed what i look to me
like explosions and starbursts emanating
from our red spot i fear my mind is
playing tricks on me for there has been
no record of such a violent outburst by
a heavenly body since the dawn of
astronomy i will consult her with the
peter on the morrow and hopefully glean
from him some advice on the matter on
october 19th peter sees the same as i as
i approach him with my concerns he
leveled the same with me and through our
following discussion we concluded that
there must be a powerful reaction to the
falling star i saw upon the first the
night and not the product of our own
shortcomings i am left wondering what
cataclysmic event must be taking place
upon our heavenly neighbor a word to
document this must go on and the work of
documenting scp-2399
has indeed gone on for centuries just as
the machine itself has never once ceased
in its extensive repairs it was first
spotted by modern humanity and by
extension the scp foundation in 1963. as
soon as the technology existed to send
satellites up to jupiter the foundation
began studying this frightening new foe
up close trying to get the true measure
of its abilities they discovered that
the weapon has a mysterious internal
power supply that seems impossible to
run down as well as an advanced
targeting system self-repair abilities
anti-matter weapons and matter
disrupting capabilities it also appears
to have advanced shielding systems that
make destroying it currently impossible
and seeing as it's a massive piece of
military machinery
514.18 million miles away from earth
it's impossible to truly contain that's
why the foundation has rearranged its
priorities into two new prongs regarding
scp-2399
the first is suppressing information to
avoid panic in order to achieve this the
foundation has embedded agents in all
major observatories to suppress any
sightings of the machine it has also
been conducting an active disinformation
campaign to keep it out of the public
consciousness the second prong of their
containment procedure is cutting off the
transmissions between the destroyers
creators in the triangulum galaxy and
the destroyer itself actually achieving
this goal took a miraculous feat in
aerospace engineering the barrier
satellite array this was an
unprecedented long-range satellite array
positioned in jupiter's higher orbit
designed for the specific purpose of
blocking the electromagnetic
transmissions inbound for the destroyer
these messages are intercepted decoded
and logged on the foundation database
the satellites have also been granted
some minor offensive capabilities for
use in extreme emergencies
scp-2399 has been given the ketter class
due to its unique containment
difficulties it's also been given
disruption class amida for the hefty
possibility that reaching earth could
result in an sk class barren earth and
the world scenario on top of that it has
been given the risk class danger due to
the very high potential of all this
actually coming to pass the biggest
concern for the foundation at present is
the accelerating rate of repair that the
destroyer seems to be exhibiting back
when they first observed the destroyer
up close it was repairing itself at a
rate of 0.12
however that rate of repair has now
risen 2.78
annually according to all known metrics
its current level of functionality
appears to be 59
if it ever reaches 75 percent then to
put it mildly we're all going to be in a
lot of trouble current projections say
this is incredibly likely to occur in
the next 25 years and if we don't figure
out a way to stop it before then the
earth is doomed the scp foundation
received a chilling wake-up call about
the severity of the situation when one
of the barrier units noticed one of the
destroyers repair drones zeroing in on a
piece of debris that seemed to be part
of the destroyer's communications array
considering that the foundation's main
weapon against the destroyer right now
is blocking its communication
capabilities allowing it to repair its
communications array would be an
unacceptable failure because of this
barrier unit 53 was ordered to fire its
onboard concussion batteries at the
drone in hopes of destroying it or at
least impeding its progress this was met
by swift and severe prevention and
retaliation from the destroyer it fired
its own defensive charges destroying
barrier unit 53's payload 5 kilometers
away from the repair drone it
subsequently destroyed barrier unit 53
as well as several other barrier
satellites that just so happened to be
in its vicinity this led to an order
that no barrier units are permitted to
engage the repair drones for fear that
this would lead to even greater losses
the next attempt to fight back against
scp-2399 went by the name project gigas
this was a joint project between the scp
foundation and 45 different nations with
the goal of using sheer raw firepower to
destroy or at least utterly incapacitate
scp-2399 they would place almost 100
massive nuclear warheads on europa
jupiter's smallest galilean moon each
one fitted with emp detonators to impede
the destroyer's defense systems they
would hit it with so much nuclear
hellfire that it surely would be
destroyed naturally when this failed to
meaningfully damage the destroyer the
foundation returned to the drawing board
daunted by the enormity of the task
before them the way they saw it there
was only one viable option left protocol
legionnaire randall mcallen the director
of the barrier project released the
following haunting memo on the subject
so
scp-2399
have you ever sat and wondered maybe
after you hear about a car accident on a
street you were just on for a bombing in
a city you were visiting just how lucky
you are to be alive just how many things
have to go right for you to continue to
exist a few seconds too late a few
seconds too early and somebody reaches
for something they dropped and a busload
of people run into another busload of
people sometimes this kind of thing does
happen as we've seen far too often but
that's what we're here for to protect
those who can't protect themselves from
things that they wouldn't even know to
protect themselves from we can't do it
all though as many things as we've been
able to contain as many things as we've
been able to keep under lock that would
threaten to destroy us all still far too
many remain that we can't do anything
about whether they're too big or too
fast or too powerful any of these things
could blink and wipe humanity from
existence the fact that they haven't
done so yet is just luck scp-2399
is however different we have little
information regarding
scp-2399's motives origins and full
capabilities we do not understand how it
is capable of communicating over such
large distances or why those who
constructed it if it was in fact
constructed sent it to us in the first
place we do not know what would happen
if
scp-2399 is able to fully repair itself
or if part of our array would break down
and any message would get through we do
not know this so we must assume the
worst judging by what we've seen where
scp-2399 to have reached earth it would
have led to our timely destruction but
sometimes humanity gets a little help
sometimes something steps in the way of
the apocalypse for us and for scp-2399
it was jupiter as
scp-2399 began to slow on its approach
to earth cassini saw what we've been
able to ascertain that
scp-2399 struck io was damaged and was
unable to escape the gravitational pull
of jupiter his weapons activated as they
were intended but it was jupiter that
experienced doomsday
not us
eventually though it is likely that
scp-2399 will resume full functionality
and will likely be able to pull away
from jupiter and proceed to its target
as of now we can keep hurdling bombs and
emps at it all we want but we've got no
indication that any of it will so much
as scratch the thing on the contrary
experience dictates that it would do
nothing at all if this were to happen
now we would undoubtedly be destroyed
jupiter has given us some time for now
scp-2399 will remain there reassembling
itself while we devise some way to stop
it like it or not we are in an arms race
with this thing our best guesses give us
something like 25 years until it is able
to hear past our dampening array until
then we must seize the opportunity that
has been laid before us we must use the
time we have been given and not let it
be wasted so we devised protocol
legionnaire one gigantic emp powered by
god knows what followed by a volley of
nukes big enough to wipe out our
civilization a thousand times over a
blunt plan and simple and likely futile
our researchers and researchers around
the globe have yet to devise even a way
to deliver that kind of pulse let alone
a way to power it there is no indication
whatsoever that we will be able to
complete legionnaire on time or if it
will do what it is intended once it is
completed but we must try we must do
something even if we have to drain our
banks and empty our minds we must try
not often do we get the chance to see
the swerving bus that will end our lives
and step out of the way jupiter
unknowingly has offered us that chance i
suggest we take it you're probably
wondering why is mcallen approaching
this situation with such desperate
urgency well it's because in 1996 and
again in 2015 the message that the
destroyer has been receiving
changed it was no longer a simple order
to repair the message now read
and if that message ever gets through
time is already up for all of us now go
check out
scp-001 oboro cycle the full story
compilation and scp-xk class end of the
world scenarios explain for more
anomalies that could wipe us off the
face of the earth